POPULISM, NO AMERICA, MY FIRST
FOURTH AS AN AMERICAN, I COULD
NOT BE MORE PROUD, AS YOU KNOW,
A COUPLE OF MONTHS AGO, I BECAME
A U.S. CITIZEN, I AM SO HAPPY TO
CELEBRATE THIS SPECIAL DAY WITH
YOU, MY FELLOW AMERICANS.
IT STILL NEW FOR ME TO SAY BUT
IT HAS FELT LIKE MY HOME FOR
YEARS, SINCE WE MOVED ACROSS THE
POND TO CALIFORNIA NEARLY A
DECADE AGO.
THE MORE I HAVE LEARNED ABOUT
AMERICA THE MORE I LOVE IT AND
THE MORE APPRECIATE THERE IS NO
BETTER PLACE ON EARTH.
THAT IS WHY I WAS OFFENDED BY
WHAT JEN PSAKI SAID AT PODIUM AT
WHITE HOUSE TO BEHALF OF THE
PRESIDENT.
IN STRONG TO THE ATHLETE
DISRESPECTING OUR FLAG AND
ANTHEM, JEN PSAKI SAYING IT IS
OKAY BECAUSE AMERICA HAS NOT
ALWAYS LIVED UP TO OUR HIGHEST
IDEALS, WHAT A LUDACRIS, SHALLOW
AND DIVISIVE THING TO DO.
OUR IDEALS ARE HIGH, MAYBE EVEN
UNATTAINABLE, BUT THE POINT IS
THEY SERVE AS A OPPORTUNITY
FIING ASPIRATION FOR THE NATION,
WE KNOW WHAT JOHN SACKY WAS
TALKING -- JEN PSAKI OF THE
TALKING ABOUT IT WAS RACE, TRUE
TODAY THERE IS STILL FAR TOO
MUCH RACIAL INJUSTICE IN THE
COUNTRY, BUT AS WOE ACKNOWLEDGE
THAT, CAN ANYONE NAME A SINGLE
COUNTRY ON EARTH, THAT OFFERS
MORE OPPORTUNITY TO THOSE FROM
ANY RACE AND ABOUT BACKGROUND
THAN AMERICA?
WHETHER THESE PEOPLE LIKE JEN
PSAKI, SO QUICK TO DEN GREAT
AMERICA -- DEN GREAT AMERICA,
WHERE DO THEY THINK IS A BETTER
PLACE TO LIVE.
WHY DO THE ATHLETES, ACTIVISTS,
THE SELF HATING TALKING HEADS
THAT SPEAR EXPHIER -- SMEAR THE
ONE COUNTRY THAT GIVE CHANCES TO
IMMIGRANTS IN THE WORLD.
WHY DO THEY WANT TO COME HERE?
TO AMERICA?
IF THIS COUNTRY IS SO RACIST?
SO STRONG -- RACIST?
MY PARENTS GROUP UP UNDER
COMMUNISM IN HUNGARY, THEY HAD A
BORDER WALL, IT OF TO KEEP
PEOPLE IN.
AMERICA NEEDS A BORDER WALL TO
KEEP PEOPLE OUT, TOO MANY
PEOPLE, FROM ALL OVER THE WORLD
WANT TO COME HERE, DOES THAT
SOUND LIKE A PLACE TO BE ASHAMED
OF?
, NOT IT SOMETHING TO BE PROUD
OF.
THE FACT THIS COUNTRY IS NUMBER
ONE CHOICE FOR ANYONE SEEK
OPPORTUNITY.
AND WHEN PEOPLE COME HERE, IN
THE LEGAL WAY, IT IS THE ONLY
PLACE IN THE WORLD THAT TRULY
FULLY WELCOMES EVERYONE IN TO
NATIONAL FAMILY OH, -- E-- ON
EQUAL TERMS, YOU COULD MOVE TO
BRITAIN BUT THEY WILL NEVER
REALLY CONSIDER YOU BRITISH.
TRY MOVING TO FRANCE AND CALLING
YOURSELF FRENCH.
CHINA?
FORGET ABOUT IT.
WHO WANTS TO MOVE TO CHINA AND
WAY.
HERE, ANYONE CAN BECOME AN
AMERICAN, I JUST DID, BEING
AMERICAN IS NOT JUST ABOUT THE
PHYSICAL SPACE BUT THE IDEAS, WE
REPRESENT.
THE IDEAS THAT AMERICA WAS BUILD
ON THE IDEAS THAT EVERY
IMPORTANT, OLD OR NEW SHOULD
PROUDLY SUPPORT.
IN OUR FOUNDING DOCUMENTS, THE
IDEAS WE CELEBRATE TODAY, AS A
NEW CITIZEN, I'M NOT HERE TO
TURN AMERICA TO THE PLACE I LEFT
BUT HELP PRESERVE, AND PROTECT
WHAT MAKES AMERICA SPECIAL.
THERE IS A REASON OUR ENEMIES
FEAR US AND OUR ALLIES' TO BE
US, THEY KNOW THE POWER OF THE
CONSTITUTION, WHICH GUARANTEES
FREEDOMS AND RIGHTS THATTERS --
THAT ARE THE BASIS OF EVERYTHING
THAT AMERICA HAS ACHIEVED.
AT HEART OF IT CHECKS AND
BALANCES, LIMITS ON THE
CONCENTRATION OF POWER, THAT IS
WHY I ARGUE WE SHOULD PAY MORE
ATTENTION TO THE CONFIDENT
TESTIMONY.
-- 10 AMENDMENT.
POWER TO THE PEOPLE, THAT IS
WHAT CREATES THE AMERICAN
SPIRIT.
TO PURSUE THE AMERICAN DREAM,
TAKING RISKS, CHASING SUCCESS.
THAT IS REWARDED HERE, NOT
PUNISHED OR LOOKED DOWN UP UPON.
TODAY, CONSTITUTION THE AMERICAN
SPIRIT AND THE AMERICAN IDEA IS
UNDER ATTACK FROM THE
CONCENTRATION MUCH POWER IN THE
HANDS OF BIG TECH, OUR POWER TO
ABOUT WHAT WE CAN SEE, READ AND
HEAR.
THE AMERICAN IDEA IS UNDER
ATTACK FROM BIG GOVERNMENT.
I'M NOT SURE PEOPLE HAVE WOKEN
UP TO THE SCALE OF WHAT IS BEING
PLANNED IN WASHINGTON RIGHT NOW,
THEY ARE PLOTTING TO TURN
AMERICA INTO A EUROPEAN-STYLE
WELFARE STATE.
MOST OF THE POPULATION DEPENDING
ON GOVERNMENT, MASSIVE TAXES TO
PAY FOR IT.
EMBOLDENED BY PANDEMIC POWER
GRAP GRAB.
THE LOCKDOWN LUNATICS,
UNLEASHING AFTERNOON ARMY OF
BUS
BODIES AND MICROMANAGERS, IN A
WAY THAT IS NOT JUST
UNACCEPTABLE BUT
UNCONSTITUTIONAL.
THERE IS NO QUESTION THAT THE
FEDERAL GOVERNMENT SHOULD NOT BE
PROVIDING THE HEALTH CARE, THESE
ARE MATTERS FOR THE STATES AND
FOR THE PEOPLE, THE CONSTITUTION
IS CLEAR, OUR AMERICAN IDEA IS
UNDER ATTACK FROM CHINA TOO.
PULLING STRINGS OF HOLLYWOOD,
CORPORATE AMERICA AND
ESTABLISHMENT MEDIA TO SUBVERT
AMERICAN INTEREST, THE CEO OF
NIKE, WHO GAVE THE GAME AWAY, WE
ARE A BRAND THAT IS MUCH CHINA
AND FOR CHINA, DON'T THE USEFUL
IDIOTS UNDERSTAND, DO THEY NOT
BOTHER TO READ WHEN THE CHINESE
LEADERS SAY, CLEARLY SAYING
THEIR GOAL TO TOPPLE AMERICA AS
WORLD'S SUPER POWER BY 1929.
-- 2029.
LOOK AT WHAT THEY ARE ALREADY
DOING GENOCIDE AND TORTURE.
WE HAVE TO FIGHT BACK.
AND IT STARTS WITH A DECOUPLING
OF OUR ECONOMIES, WE MUST STRIKE
AT THE FOUNDATION OF CHINA'S
RIDE.
THE AMERICAN IDEA IS UNDER
ATTACK FROM WOKEISM.
THE HATEFUL, INTOLERANT IDEOLOGY
THAT CAPTURED THE MOST POWERFUL
INSTITUTIONS IN AMERICA FROM
BOARDROOM TO OVAL OFFICE.
HIJACKING OUR LANGUAGE, TURNING
AMERICANS AGAIN EACH OTHER,
PUSHING HATE AND DIVISION AND
RACISM.
IN ANY CASE, AS I HAVE POINTED
OUT.
THE MAIN DRIVER OF RACIAL
INJUSTICE IN AMERICA TODAY IS
NOT RACISTS WHITE PEOPLE FROM 18
SENTRY CENTURY BUT RACE OBSESSED
DEMOCRATS.
IT IS CONSERVATIVE IDEAS LIKE
STRONG FAMILIES AND SCHOOL
CHOICE.
THAT OFFER THE BEST PROSPECT OF
ACHIEVING WHAT WE WANT TO SEE
EQUAL OPPORTUNITY FOR EVERY
AMERICAN.
ON THIS JULY 4, REMEMBER WHO WE
ARE AS AMERICANS WHAT WE STAND
FOR, THIS COUNTRY FUTURE IS
BRIGHT AS LONG AS WE GET UP OFF
OUR KNEES AND DEFEND IT.
TAKE ON CHINA AND DEFEA